Here's a question for you. Say, it takes roughly the same amount of time to
compute the lighting at a vertex as it does per pixel. You're trying to get some
idea of how much more expensive it is to draw objects using the material
evaluation, using fragment shading instead of vertex shading. In other words,
Phong shading instead of Gouraud shading. Say your object and application has
the following characteristics. Each vertex on the mesh is squared by an average
of 5 triangles. That is, any vertex where we compute the materials color can be
shared among 5 triangles. On average, each triangle covers 60 pixels. Don't
worry about visibility. Assume the pixel shader is evaluated for all of these
pixels in a triangle. So, the question to you is how many reflection evaluations
are needed for, per pixel versus per vertex shading? In other words Phong versus
Gouraud Shading.